hola bienvenidos a migrantes el programa
semanal de france 24 sobre el éxodo los
saluda juliet riaño
[Música]
la respuesta de eeuu a la llegada masiva
de migrantes haitianos a su territorio
generó todo tipo de reacciones el
gobierno de joe biden decidió deportar a
unas 2.000 personas y las envió de
vuelta a un país en crisis además las
tácticas usadas por agentes fronterizos
para contener el paso terminaron en
rechazo internacional y aunque la
llegada de una administración demócrata
a la casa blanca empujó a miles a
avanzar en el camino la realidad es que
el gobierno va a ir en se valió de una
de las medidas adoptadas por trump para
justificar las expulsiones hoy miles de
haitianos están a kilómetros del llamado
sueño americano veamos lo que pasa ahora
con algunos de ellos de un campamento
con casi 15.000 migrantes en del río en
texas a un espacio completamente vacío
en cuestión de días los migrantes en su
mayoría haitianos que buscaban refugio
en eeuu ya no están algunos fueron
deportados otros conducidos a centros de
procesamiento y unos más regresaron por
su cuenta a mexico donde se concentra
ahora la crisis migratoria en ciudad
acuña al lado mexicano de la frontera se
levantó un refugio para recibir a los
que retornaron al país y que solo se
planteaban a méxico como una nación de
tránsito aquí yo me siento muy bien todo
el mundo está feliz por este lugar que
ofrece para todo el mundo
una fuera fuera tiene mucho mucho
bastante comida para todos jugos comidas
amuletos
el lugar para poner bien
bien limpio
aquí es muy muy bueno
mucho
muchas gracias para quien quiere ser su
separarnos y es que a diferencia de lo
ocurrido en los últimos días en texas
aquí reciben atención masiva la
intención ahorita pues es ofrecerles
atención médica en general consulta
médica general y también detectar si
alguna de las personas que vienen de
fuera
si tienen alguna enfermedad
que pueda ser infectocontagiosas
específicamente de enfermedades sujetas
a vigilancia
epidemiológica sin embargo las
autoridades mexicanas buscan que este no
sea un lugar definitivo en el instituto
nacional de migración planea
transportarlos hasta tapachula en la
frontera sur con guatemala donde se
ubica el centro de detención migratoria
más grande de américa latina aquí no
quiero solamente que se transmite como
para trabaja y tiene un vida buena busca
trabajo tiene vida y tiene un futuro
actualmente ante las últimas noticias
que llegaron desde la frontera con eeuu
algunos migrantes decidieron comenzar
trámites para quedarse en méxico
salir la noche para bajar
en búsqueda de nuevas oportunidades
entonces creo que sí va a seguir
creciendo y nosotros como autoridades
algo debemos de hacer
[Música]
pero la realidad es que las
posibilidades de asilo para los
haitianos en mexico no son muchas en
2020 sólo el 22 por ciento de los casos
obtuvieron aprobación en comparación con
las aceptadas de otras nacionalidades
las deportaciones hacia haití incluyeron
a personas en condición de
vulnerabilidad que muy posiblemente
aplicaban como candidatas a obtener
asilo el retorno además se realizó a una
nación prácticamente desconocida para
ellos ya que muchos de los migrantes
salieron hace años de haití el país de
hoy no es el mismo que dejaron para
algunos fueron hasta 10 años lejos de
haití y no planeaban regresar este fue
un retorno inesperado a una nación en la
que las oportunidades son incluso peores
a las que había cuando decidieron
emigrar
único delito fue que haber vivido nunca
quise agregar mi vida durante ocho días
en el desierto eeuu
hacen parte de los haitianos que eeuu
decidió reportar después del
represamiento en la ciudad del río en
texas
en las calles de puerto príncipe los
haitianos rechazaron las deportaciones
masivas y pidieron respeto
no estamos aquí para pedir favores a
eeuu
los que nos respeten como el piano si
como migrantes tenemos derechos
ya nos han sido maltratados han sido
golpeados los han metido en una prisión
fría los han subido aviones para ser
deportados a haití esto es una violación
además eeuu ha violado las convenciones
internacionales sobre inmigración que
han sido firmadas por varios países del
mundo
muchos de los expulsados vivieron
durante años en brasil y chile como
jones el stan y su familia estuvieron
tres años en chile pero ahora comparten
una pequeña habitación en puerto
príncipe con un primo que también fue
deportado
nos llevaron a un lugar donde nos
dijeron que se pondrían con nuestra
familia y que nos encontraríamos con
ellos en miami florida todo el mundo
estaba feliz pero yo no lo estaba y
ambas hubo agua así quedarse en haití no
es una opción y por eso planean volver a
emigrar su país es ahora más violento
pobre e inestable políticamente que la
nación que dejaron
lo cierto es que el tránsito hacia eeuu
está lejos de solucionarse abordar las
causas de la migración sigue siendo un
tema pendiente y en el camino hay otros
miles que también tienen como destino a
la unión americana hasta que inmigrantes
de france24 los invitamos a comentar en
nuestras redes sociales con el hashtag
migrantes f24 siga con más información
en france 24 y france 24 puntocom
[Música]